the development of The Witcher 3 is by
far one of the most ambitious projects
you have ever done and it continuously
amazes me like how we have managed to
pull all of this off which is such a
small team must give you something
what's that a mark to show we're if you
think that playing The Witcher Wild Hunt
is a memorable experience imagine what
making it meant for us cadre playing a
very positive aspect of working at CD
Projekt RED is that your voice in your
opinion they really matter in fact
everyone here is counting on it on your
own proactiveness in making this game
better there are countless examples of
things that were added to the game
thanks to suggestions and meetings or
conversations in the corridor even
reading comments on internet forums and
of course let's not forget that Wendt
was born in a bathtub all of these
people have been injecting their
personal experiences into everything
that they do and it somehow shows
actually in this creative art form
we've said this a million times and I'll
say it again we're gamers first of all
and we all like to be treated fairly so
it only makes sense that as developers
we apply the same principle to
everything we do here at CD Projekt RED
you buying the game it actually is a
very big deal for us it allows us to
keep doing what we do best these big
vast role-playing games so giving
everyone a bunch of free DLC was an
absolutely no brainer you were invested
in us and we want to make sure that you
feel like your money was well spent
parts of some expansion pack which has
just been released this is not a normal
DLC this is something rather special it
took us a very long time to make and it
has an enormous amount of content it
does have a price tag but we hope that
once you see how big it is you'll find
it absolutely justified fire and blood
life and death I summon gene whose blood
I have brought
parts of stone this expansion is not an
additional quest it's not an additional
monster on notice not a series of
additional mechanics it's all those
things in multiples and more this
expansion pack is gonna bring new items
new gameplay mechanics and even you
monsters that will integrate seamlessly
into the main game but this expansion is
all about the story and what a story it
is monster in the sewers know anything
more no clue what it is
only that it's deadly nothing bothered
at my cook dr. ko is fixing the way she
prepared game but no a cool it's a full
and I think fascinating and fun story or
series of stories that rather nicely
issue from and tie back into the main
game Geralt meets an immortal and gets a
series of tasks that seem impossible at
first not least because they involve
challenging combat and complex
investigations gameplay the ties closely
into the story what's it guilty of do
you not your concern me
and we give you the tools to meet these
challenges and quite a number of new
beasts you get added items and an
all-new mechanic that lets you craft
room words and glyph moves both of which
that you fine-tune Geralt is gear and
abilities oh and take plenty of coin
have a feeling it could come in handy
and the action as always will be richly
varied you'll rebel with a ghost at a
wedding seeing both Geralt and a
spectral companion through a series of
interesting situations that provide the
kind of comic relief seldom before seen
in the franchise well you ain't need to
go in wearing that what else you'll join
in a daring heist handling everything
from the planning through putting
together crew to negotiating your way
out of a bind if things go sour and
you'll romance someone kind of new if
you so choose Johnny yeah in something
of a tip of a hat to those gamers who
have been with The Witcher franchise
since its inception during production of
The Witcher Wild Hunt we estimated that
players could easily spend over a
hundred hours in this game and that
actually turned out to be a very
accurate prediction for the hearts of
stone expansion packed we estimate that
it will take you 10 hours maybe more and
that is a lot of contents if you haven't
bought this game yet I honestly believe
that you should ask your friends about
it because no other person out there
could describe this rollercoaster ride
of your input
oh and one more thing guys like we are
still supporting the main game so if you
have any feedback whatsoever please just
go to our social channels and we would
absolutely love to hear from you